[Music]
of course there's a lot of controversy
right now in the news and in America
over what it means to wear a hoodie in
public a lot of discussion on this even
yesterday congressman Bobby Rush was
kicked off the House floor for wearing a
hoodie while speaking out against racial
profiling check out this photo there he
is actually speaking wearing a hoodie
and so everyone's talking about it it's
getting more and more heated here to try
to make some sense of this hoodie
controversy is one of our writers Deon
Cole yeah
thanks Conan what in the world is going
oh yeah since winter we're in the
snuggly ass hoodie become a national
threat huh I mean some of my favorite
people wear hoodies like Kenny from
South Park what about the Jawas from
Star Wars
and what about cuddly Bill Belichick
okay that's a bad example right there
I'm sorry about that
but what about my man from the video
game Assassin's Creed huh hey check out
that slick hoodie got on he look badass
right yeah but you all want him to lose
his hoodie so here we go look I don't
want to live in a world like that people
but I get it and I know what this is
about so I figured out a way to rock a
hoodie without looking threatening to
anyone check it out
[Applause]
now if I'm in a really white
neighborhood I gotta say it's a very
very good Deon don't pull me be I wanna
wear on this call me chip Martin - [ __ ]
[Applause]